hasta ahorita ya hemos trabajado con una
de las definiciones de la integral
definida que es justo hasta que tengo
aquí y de hecho todas las demás
definiciones de la integral definida son
muy parecidas a ésta es decir la
integral definida de ave de esta función
de fx de x es justo esta área que tengo
coloreada de azul y bueno lo que vimos
fue que nosotros podemos obtener una
buena aproximación si dividimos esta
área completa que tengo aquí en pequeños
rectángulos es decir si yo me tomo aquí
al primero de ellos déjame ponerlo más o
menos así ok a esta parte por aquí ok
después me tomo el segundo vamos a verlo
más o menos así ok
más o menos así y después me sigo
tomando varios de ellos este es el
primero este es el segundo y por aquí
llegó hasta el n menos uno que va a ser
este de aquí
déjame tomarlo por acá y este va a ser
mi penúltimo de ellos ok y por acá voy a
decir que me tomo al último de ellos que
es este de aquí es decir este último de
aquí y bueno para hacernos las cosas más
fáciles en este vídeo voy a suponer que
todos tienen
mismo ancho que cada uno de estos
rectángulos tiene el mismo ancho
entonces este es el n ok y bueno voy a
decir que el ancho es exactamente el
mismo para todos los rectángulos y el
ancho lo voy a llamar delta x y bueno
recuerda que hemos visto algunas
definiciones de integral en donde no
forzosamente deben de tener el mismo
ancho sin embargo aquí para hacer las
cosas de una manera mucho más sencilla
se puede decir que es el mismo ancho
para cada uno de esos rectángulos que es
delta x y como ya hemos visto a delta x
lo podemos calcular de la siguiente
manera es exactamente igual que tomarme
am - am ok
b - ah ok la diferencia entre estos dos
ya esto dividirlo ya esto dividirlo ok
entre n n que va a ser la cantidad de
rectángulos que no voy a tomar así que
déjame ponerlo así ya esto lo voy a
dividir entre n lo cual tiene mucho
sentido con bueno todo lo que hemos
visto de divisiones si nosotros tomamos
esta longitud de este segmento y lo
dividimos entre n partes
bueno pues cada una de estas
va a tener la misma longitud que por
cierto es delta x y entonces podemos
decir que esto va a ser exactamente
igual a la suma ok a la suma de quién
bueno desde y igual a 1 ok
desde iu igual a uno hasta n me voy a
tomar la suma de todas las áreas que
tengo aquí como tenemos en rectángulos
me estoy tomando el área de todos estos
rectángulos ok de quien como encontramos
esa área bueno pues multiplicando a efe
de x 26 de x sub índice y ok am donde
recuerda que x subíndice y es el punto
final en donde termina nuestro
rectángulo en este caso tendríamos x
subíndice 1 que date cuenta que nos da
esta cierta altura lo cual es efe de x
subíndice y aquí tengo x 1 aquí tengo x
2 aquí tendrían x 3 y bueno todos los
demás ya esto lo multiplicamos por el
ancho pero el ancho sabemos que es delta
x entonces a esto lo multiplicamos por
delta x por ejemplo si hablamos de x
subíndice 2 bueno
efe de x subíndice 2 es y aquí tenemos a
x subíndice 2 iba a ser esta altura que
tengo aquí este es de x subíndice 2 ok
esta parte que tengo aquí y bueno si a
esto lo multiplicó por delta x ok que es
esta parte de aquí bueno a esto lo
multiplicó por delta x entonces date
cuenta que me da justo esta esta área
que tengo aquí que es justo lo que yo
quiero de lujo entonces esta expresión
lo que me está dando es la suma de todas
estas áreas y esto no tiene nada nuevo
porque de hecho lo hemos platicado
cuando nosotros hablábamos de la
integral de riman nosotros lo que vimos
fue que cuando teníamos esta integral
igual al límite ok al límite o déjenme
poner que esta es una l al límite cuando
n tiende a infinito ok de todos estos
rectángulos entonces nos daba la famosa
integral de riman donde claro está delta
de x está definido de esta manera así
que déjame ponerlo donde ok donde
definimos a delta de x de esta manera
esta es una forma de pensarlo así que
déjame atraparlo lo voy a copiar por
aquí ok y lo voy a poner justo por acá
esta es una manera de pensar este
problema ahora dada esta definición en
cómo piensas que podemos ver la
siguiente integral qué te parece si
ahora pensamos en esta integral integral
debe hasta a de f de x ok de x y bueno
esto pensado en relación a esta integral
que tengo aquí arriba es decir cómo
puedo relacionar estas dos integrales
utilizando esta definición y ojo lo
único que estoy haciendo es cambiando
los límites de integración aquí voy de
am hasta b y aquí voy a ir de b hasta a
como están relacionadas estas 2
integrales y te encargo que te fijes muy
bien en esta expresión que tengo aquí
para que saque sus propias conclusiones
así que en este momento pausa el vídeo
para que llegues a tu propia respuesta
y bueno seguramente te vas a dar cuenta
que es muy parecido a esto de hecho voy
a atrapar esto que tengo aquí lo voy a
tratar todo todo todo y lo voy a copiar
y lo voy a pegar porque voy a utilizarlo
exactamente a esta misma definición que
tengo aquí va a ser casi exactamente lo
mismo pero ahora va a haber una pequeña
diferencia la diferencia que va a ver es
que voy a cambiar esta esta parte que
tengo aquí déjame borrar esto y ahora en
lugar de ir y suena muy lógico en lugar
de ir de menos a me voy a tomar ahora la
diferencia de a menos pero déjame
ponerlo con este color ahora me voy a
tomar a delta de x como a menos b ok
estoy dividido entre n y ahora quiero
que te des cuenta es lo siguiente este
delta de x antes que me ponerlo con este
color naranja este delta de x de color
anaranjado este de aquí este por cierto
es este de aquí ok
va a ser exactamente igual a menos este
delta de x de color verde al menos este
delta de x que tengo de color
de este que tengo aquí es decir es la
versión negativa de este que tengo aquí
esta es la versión negativa de este que
tengo aquí y bueno todo lo demás es lo
mismo date cuenta que dejamos
exactamente igual esta parte y entonces
con que voy a acabar
bueno pues date cuenta que voy a acabar
con la versión negativa de esta integral
que tengo aquí dicho de otra manera esto
es exactamente lo mismo que tomarme
menos la integral ok
desde a hasta df df de x ok esto de x de
x y justo a este resultado quería llegar
que por cierto es una de las propiedades
más importantes que existen ok
cuando hablamos de integrales este que
va a ser mi resultado de este vídeo que
dicho de otra manera lo que me está
diciendo es que si nosotros nos tomamos
un cambio en los límites de integración
es decir si volteamos los límites de
integración que por cierto esta idea
viene de aquí arriba solamente de
cambiar un signo en este delta de x en
darnos cuenta que si está delta de x
está definido como ve - am cuando yo
cambios los límites de integración
entonces ahora este delta de x lo
podemos definir como a menos b lo cual
por cierto es la versión negativa de
este delta de x de color verde o dicho
de otra manera la versión negativa de
este delta de x original es decir que si
cambiamos este delta de x vamos a llegar
a la versión negativa de esta integral
que tengo aquí y ya está la propiedad
que quería ver en este vídeo que por
cierto es una de las propiedades más
importantes y de las propiedades más
pero más pero más útiles que tenemos
cuando hablamos de integrales la cual va
a ser mucho más sentido cuando
intentemos resolverlas